growing up with a successful sibling is
hard for anyone but that problem is
increased exponentially when that
sibling is none other than real life
tony stark elon musk and yet even in
that extremely precarious situation
elon's younger brother kimball has not
only gotten his own share of success but
is actually making an impact arguably
just as important as his brothers with
that established who exactly is kimball
musk and what does he do to answer that
question we're going to be taking you
from the very start of the musk brothers
journeys and bringing you to today so if
you're interested in finding out more
please watch the video till the end
because today we're going to find out
what goes on in the life of the younger
musk to start with let's discuss the
family history of the musks family
history as many of you may know elon was
born and raised for the first years of
his life in south africa and the same
goes for kimball a year younger than his
now famous brother kimball is the
youngest son of may and errol musk and
is the third sibling along with his
sister tosca and from the get-go as
children of a very successful model and
dietitian and an engineer kimball and
elon were introduced to everything that
would end up influencing their future by
the time they graduated the brothers had
already made the move to america start
as entrepreneurs and that was
coincidentally also where they got their
start as entrepreneurs one of the major
projects that the duo worked on back
then was zip2 a software company meant
to catalog city information and in just
four years they managed to earn nearly
300 million dollars for the website when
it was acquired by compaq in 1999. as
you can imagine it wasn't as easy as it
may seem as those few years were the
hardest work the two had to do with musk
himself recalling during a 2014
commencement speech at usc when my
brother and i were starting our first
company instead of getting an apartment
we just rented a small office and we
slept on the couch even that wasn't the
end of it he added that they showered at
the ymca and we were so hard up we had
just one computer so the website was up
during the day and i was coding at night
seven days a week and even after those
successes paid off instead of calling it
a day the two decided to continue down
the path to success with them going on
to invent x.com which elon would later
build into paypal which you may remember
sold to ebay in 2002 for a whopping 1.5
billion dollars later that year kimball
would also make what would turn out to
be one of the most profitable decisions
of his life by investing into a couple
of little startups that went by the name
of tesla and spacex two companies whose
board he's still a part of today end of
working with elon however that also
signaled the end of the brotherly duo
working together because as kimball
himself put it he and his brother have a
slightly different take on the world of
business we have similar views though
his are stratospheric while mine are
more in the ground as it would turn out
that explanation was a lot more literal
than you might think you see the
starting and ending point of kimball
musk's ventures is ultimately food and a
big part of that is farming and
agriculture according to the trained
chef as well as an engineer himself i've
always loved food growing up i cooked in
the house and when i cooked everyone
would sit down and eat and it was just
kind of the way i connected with my
family i used to throw cooking parties
in university everyone would come over
sometimes you'd just do a mac and cheese
but if you can do that better than
everyone else you can get people to come
to you and that's only one of the many
food related things that he's done over
the years after he split up from his
brother kimball moved to new york city
and enrolled in the french culinary
institute where he would learn many of
the skills that would come in handy for
his career as a start he along with
sculptor and designer jen lewin and
fellow food nerd hugo matheson
co-founded the kitchen family of
restaurants starting in boulder back in
2004 and in perfect musk fashion the
kitchen is a successful and innovative
take on an existing thing that elevates
it to a different level food business in
the case of this restaurant the name of
the game is the quality of ingredients
and the principle of using locally
sourced items with the company claiming
that they source nearly one million
dollars worth of product from local
providers it is not hard to see how
useful the impact can be on the locals
the entire establishment actually
consists of three different bits all
working together first the kitchen
upstairs a cocktail lounge with food
prepared in a wood oven and artesian
cocktails next the kitchen next door a
community pub that serves things like
burgers salads sandwiches margaritas and
beer and finally the kitchen itself a
community bistro that has since its
inception become one of the most
celebrated restaurants in the entire
country being declared as such by
amateurs and professionals alike the
kitchen community since then the idea
has expanded into the kitchen community
a non-profit that works to bring outdoor
gardens to schools around the country to
spread awareness of sustainable farming
and after just three years of existence
the nonprofit had already built 200 such
gardens in chicago los angeles and
colorado schools reaching more than 120
000 children a number which nearly
reached a million last year except for
the pandemic interfering however what
might turn out to be the most important
of adventures is something called square
roots a venture that seeks to completely
change farming by means of reclaiming
old containers and using them as
containers for controlled indoor
agriculture it's not bad for you but it
doesn't have that like
spinach benefit that you think you're
getting that you've conditioned yourself
based in brooklyn the company has
developed special modules which are
hydroponic farms in shipping containers
that can grow certain non-gmo vegetables
around the clock and without pesticides
as of today they are successfully
producing mint basil other herbs and
leafy greens right at your doorstep the
modules employ software controlled led
lighting and irrigation systems and as a
result aren't dependent on local
climatic conditions as much as
traditional agriculture and have a
lesser impact on the environment the
crops are grown in a vertical system
without soil in nutrient-rich water
under special colored led lights that
are ideal for photosynthesis and that
impact is also far-reaching since by
putting these farms right next to big
cities we can reduce the amount of food
wasted each year in transportation and
large storage areas which also ties in
nicely with kimball's brother elon since
these kinds of modules are the ones that
will eventually be used when humanity
moves on to mars as kimball himself has
said regarding the future for me i like
to think in terms of three months out
and 50 years out three months out is
what to do now 50 years out is what i
like to do before i'm dead if i look
back and see specific communities where
i made a difference using food i will
pass very peacefully now that's all well
and good but that brings us to the
biggest question of all what is the
brother of the world's richest man worth
and as you may guess it's nothing to
scoff at as a result of his extremely
valuable 0.04
stake in tesla along with the benefits
that come being a board member as well
as around 2 million dollars worth of
stock in chipotle where he is also a
director and his position on the board
of spacex kimball musk has amassed a
very hefty figure in terms of net worth
with the most conservative estimates by
forbes placing him around a value of
about 700 million dollars phew i guess
it pays to be a musk now that's enough
from the business side let's now shift
our attention to the question everyone
is asking what does his personal life
look like personal life and surprisingly
enough there's not a lot to go on
compared to other entrepreneurs who like
to flaunt their lavish lives kimball is
shockingly reserved when it comes to his
private life the same goes for his
relationships most of which have been
rather quaint and once again very
private he once told forbes that he was
married to sculptor jen lewin for a
while who you may recognize as the same
gen lewin who helped design the learning
gardens of big green and while they were
together the pair had three kids luca
stella and august all of whom enjoy a
private life lewin wouldn't be the only
work-related relationship that the
millionaire would find himself in as
after his divorce kimmel ended up with
cristiano wiley an environmentalist very
much after kimball's heart and as a
bonus a daughter of a billionaire the
famous sam wiley as an activist she
founded green mountain energy 100
renewable energy company that was later
sold for 350 million dollars and goes to
show the entrepreneurial as well as
environmental connections between the
two and after getting married in july
2018 the two seem to share a happy life
giving back to the world as much as they
can and well that covers the story of
kimmel musk elon's just as influential
albeit a lot more unlikely revolutionary
brother with which we must end today's
video i hope you enjoyed watching it and
if you did be sure to leave a like and
subscribe for more with that take care
and i'll see you guys next time